c'est une des centres les plus célèbres
de france bernadette soubirous ses
visions de la vierge à lourdes attire
chaque année 6 millions de visiteurs
depuis vendredi
ces reliques sont à tour à la basilique
saint martin une première en touraine
pour les fidèles c'est un grand moment
samuel collant saint martin est un
habitué des pèlerins mais en ce moment
dans sa basilique
les regards sont plutôt tournés vers
lourdes et ce coffret pour la première
fois en touraine les reliques de sainte
bernadette
et tout autour les croyants dans un
défilé continue ses massacres préféré je
trouve qu'elle était set c'était
formidable ce qu'il est arrivé
elle vient pour une fois jusqu'à chez
moi à tour alors que d'habitude fait la
voix donc c'est très important pour moi
puisqu'on ne peut pas aller à lourdes
donc c'est elle qui est venue vers nous
le reliquaire contient la 3è et 4è côte
de bernadette soubirous ils voyagent
déjà régulièrement dans toute l'europe
et en france aussi depuis 2010 est sous
l'impulsion du diocèse de lourdes un
cadeau du ciel pour l'hospitalité de
touraine
car avec la crise sanitaire ces deux
pèlerinages annuels sont annulés en 2020
les 400 bénévoles y accompagne
d'ordinaire une centaine de malades à
chaque fois j'ai tout de suite répondu
oui quand le père m'a appelée what
septembre on venait d'annuler le mois
d'août on est et on était triste surtout
triste de ne pas avoir ramené toutes nos
personnes qui n'attendent que ça
feuilleter un rayon cela et cette
proposition et les reliques de la
voyante des pyrénées vous encore voyager
demain à lyon au mans j'ai ensuite à
angers chartres et paris
l'hospitalité de touraine à elle déjà
annulé le pèlerinage d'avril mais espère
encore pouvoir faire le déplacement à
lourdes au mois d'août